He turned the world of art on its head, time and again.
I think there's no getting away from Picasso.
He managed to transform the whole face of art.
His canvas was his diary.
When you are brought up with someone who has such a personality,...
...you really think that's really quite normal.
His appetite for invention was insatiable,...
...so was his appetite for women.
If my husband did to me what my father did to my mother and Dora,...
...I would have killed him.
The world has never seen anyone quite like him...
...and his innovations have yet to be fully understood.
A true understanding of Picasso is live with what he did,...
...live with his ugliness, live with his barbaric cruelty upon occasion...
...and also live with the fact that it was generosity of his output of his work.